[Música]
el envío a migrantes por avión o autobús
a ciudades de mayorías electorales
demócratas por parte de gobernadores
republicanos tanto a una lujosa isla en
el noreste de Estados Unidos como a
Washington DC y la capital o la ciudad
de Nueva York ha desado toda una batalla
política en ese país en Estados Unidos
esto A pocas semanas de las cruciales
elecciones legislativas de medio término
del mes de noviembre donde además los
demócratas se juegan el control del
Congreso salud vamos entonces a nuestro
segundo invitado al día él es Rafael
piñeros experto en temas de Estados
Unidos y profesor de relaciones
internacionales de la Universidad
externado de Colombia Rafael que bueno
tenerlo nuevamente en nuestro espacio
matinal directo América de Francia 24
buena mañana Muchas gracias por la
invitación Raúl es un placer estar acá
con usted vamos entonces a hablar a
Rafael de lo que está pasando con este
envío de los migrantes no a pasiones
demócratas esto por parte de figuras
políticos prominentes repu ellos acusan
al presidente Joe biden de convertir
esta frontera sur de Estados Unidos con
México en un colador para toda esta
migración irregular
Cómo cómo cómo lee esto Rafael bueno es
sumamente preocupante que se juegue con
la vida de personas que buscan asilo o
que buscan escapar de situaciones
económicas o sociales en sus países de
origen recordemos que las nacionalidades
de las personas que han llegado tanto a
Texas como a la Florida son diversas y
reflejan la heterogeneidad de los países
latinoamericanos y por supuesto utilizar
la herramienta de enviarlos a bastiones
que pueden ser más amigos de la
inmigración como el estado de
Massachusetts Nueva York o alguno o la
capital misma sin duda alguna refleja
una estrategia
políticas pueden tener intereses
electorales no solo en las mitherms sino
de Cara a ser eventualmente
precandidatos republicanos el año
entrante por lo tienen que mostrar una
carta de fuerza y de solidez en control
de la migración y también distintos
informes han mostrado como esas medidas
de enviar migrantes a otros lugares No
necesariamente va a solucionar el
problema qué preocupa preocupa que un
informe que salió la semana anterior
muestra cómo en el año fiscal que
estamos terminando más de dos millones
de personas llegaron a la frontera sur
de los Estados Unidos ni la estrategia
de Donald Trump disminuir al mínimo
cualquier tipo de migración ni las
estrategias demócratas recordemos que la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris fue
encargada en el año 2021 de lidiar con
el problema migratorio ha ido dos veces
a Centroamérica y ha prometido sendo
recursos para paliar o para evitar la
migración en el lugar de origen tampoco
han dado resultado Entonces el sistema
disfuncional de inmigración
estadounidense hace agua no hay un
camino Expedito ni para legalizar a los
migrantes ni para solucionar las
dificultades que se presentan en algunos
pasos fronterizos y en algunas ciudades
que sin duda alguna es bastante
complicado de controlar en ciudades como
el paso en Texas hay más de 1200
migrantes que están llegando diariamente
y esa situación no se puede controlar de
una manera fácil o sencilla Rafael
Entonces cómo están las cosas Pues los
mayores favorecidos con todo esto serían
los republicanos porque también
recordemos que el ex presidente Donald
Trump decida que con la llegada de los
demócratas al poder Pues iba a aumentar
toda esta migración la migración
irregular y van a llegar más migrantes
pues está cumpliendo de alguna manera
todo esto que favorece a una digamos
entre comillas predicción que pudo hacer
el presidente Donald Trump pero ajeno
digamos a una realidad del país
estuviera un republicano estuviera un
demócrata esta migración igual si
hubiera incrementado con el pasar de los
tiempos porque también pues el problema
de raíz el problema sobre todo en
Centroamérica pues no evolucionado
también como lo decías bien la
presidenta cámara Harris se fue pues una
nombrada especial del presidente
yobaiden para resolver esto y pues vemos
que el problema en vez de disminuirse ha
aumentado porque está pasando esto
también Rafael yo creo que los enfoques
de cada uno de los partidos han sido
equivocados el presidente Donald Trump
mostró y sigue mostrando los demócratas
como el partido amigo de El crimen y los
demócratas han mencionado en repetidas
ocasiones que la mejor manera de
combatir la migración ilegal o irregular
es a partir de facilitar la migración
legal pero ninguno de los dos ha sido lo
suficientemente claro los republicanos
exigen y desean más fondos federales
para
reforzar los controles migratorios en
las zonas fronterizas pero esa situación
No necesariamente alivia es decir tener
más pie de fuerza y tener mejores
mecanismos para combatir la inmigración
ilegal no genera que haya una disuasión
de los migrantes que pretenden llegar a
la frontera y por lo tanto un paso
Expedito hacia la nacionalidad y hacia
la legalización de millones de migrantes
ha sido un elemento que se ha truncado
muchas veces en el congreso para
resumirte básicamente pareciera que lo
republicanos quisieran seguir
manteniendo el problema porque tampoco
ofrecen una solución lo suficientemente
sólida que sea viable para ambos
partidos por ejemplo
la presidenta de la cámara ha abogado en
distintas ocasiones teniendo en cuenta
la preocupación que le genera a muchos
legisladores demócratas el hecho de no
reforzar las fronteras y ha pasado
centros proyectos de ley en la cámara de
representantes para incrementar el
número de policías y el número de
recursos disponibles para combatir la
inmigración legal pero eso tampoco ha
sucedido no ha pasado de manera clara
porque hay una fuerte oposición por
parte de los demócratas tal vez que
mencionan que reforzar los cuerpos de
policía No necesariamente se va en una
disminución de los de los migrantes que
llegan a la zona de fronteras vamos a
hablar allá de algunos escenarios
posibles algunas soluciones a este
problema que además tiene años por
supuesto en Estados Unidos Rafael pero
volviendo al tema de enviar estos
migrantes allí así siniestra digamos que
tanto poder o qué tan legal es que los
republicanos en este caso pues se metan
a esas personas en aviones y en
autobuses para enviarlos a cualquier
lugar de Estados Unidos que ellos
consideren donde tienen que estar
digamos que no sé si las autoridades
federales tienen al pueden tener algún
tipo de freno para que esto no siga
sucediendo Cuál es cuál es la potestad
que tienen los republicanos para hacer
esto con había una persona y decidir de
alguna manera el destino a ellos en la
década de los 80 se empezó a conocer lo
que se conoce como ciudades santuario es
decir ciertas ciudades en los Estados
Unidos que son más amigables a la
inmigración Chicago Nueva York
Washington DC Los Ángeles ciudades
grandes que se caracterizan por acoger a
un gran número de inmigrantes no es una
práctica legal y no es una práctica
correcta en la medida en que no hay
ningún tipo de coordinación ni entre el
que envía es decir los gobernadores de
Texas Florida o Arizona y el que recibe
porque sin duda alguna no ha habido
ningún diálogo al respecto sino que
suben a una a un gran número de personas
a buses les prometen que van a ser
acogidos con trabajo con casa con
eventualmente un empleo pero estas
promesas No necesariamente se cumplen Y
eso genera sin duda alguna una una
situación indeseable desde el punto de
vista humano y al mismo tiempo
preocupante desde el punto de vista
político porque los republicanos o los
estados republicanos no se pueden
refugiar en esa práctica para disminuir
o para disuadir a los migrantes que
llegan a sus estados o a